الذي حدث وتم التحريف للتحريض ضد مصر انه
قيل بان المصري يقول بان القران هو منتج
انتهت صلاحيته ونص لم يكن هذا اطلاقا نص
دائما كان يؤكد انا لاناقش ان القران من
عند الله او من غير عند الله انا اقول
بالقران من عند الله ولكن اتحدث فيه كان
رساله في بنيه لغويه في حاجه الى تحديد في
حاجه الى دراسه وفقا لطبيعتها كميه لغويه
حتى نستطيع ان نميز بداخلها ما بين
التاريخ ما بين الزمن المحدد وما بين
المعرفي الانساني الخالق ونحن حتى عندما
نقول في المعنى التاريخي حتى يكون هناك
التحرير في العباره نقول بان هناك حكم
تعطل حكم او خطاب انتهاء والزمالك
قالوا انه انه هو بينكر
انه القران من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
وانه بينكر
بيقول انه انه بشري
وبيقول انه منتج ثقافي وطبعا ده كله كان
عباره عن استهزاء يصل الى حد الجريمه
الكامله يعني لانه
دكتور مصري قال ايه القران الهي المصدر
بشري اللغه والثقافه يعني الهيه يعني جامع
عند ربنا
من عند ربنا لكن ربنا ينزله بلغه مين بلغه
البشر بلغه العرب باللغه العربيه